for the 55th night in a row
protesters flooded the streets of
portland but there's a new chant
being sung
that's go home a clear message to the
federal agents deployed by the trump
administration to crack down
on demonstrators what are you doing
their presence is sparked controversy
dressed in military gear
the unidentified officers have been
accused of arbitrarily arresting
more than 40 protesters some like this
demonstrator
hauled away in unmarked vans to
undisclosed locations
the local governor a democrat not
mincing her words
this is a democracy not a dictatorship
we cannot have secret police
abducting people into and putting them
in
unmarked vehicles i cannot believe i
have to
say that to the president of the united
states i know that oregonians are
outraged
americans should be appalled but the
controversy hasn't stopped president
trump announcing that more federal
agents
will be sent to other u.s cities
today i'm announcing a surge of federal
law enforcement into american
communities plagued by violent crime
will work
every single day to restore public
safety
protect our nation's children and bring
violent
perpetrators to justice federal officers
will be sent to albuquerque and chicago
both democrat-run cities critics say the
deployment is political
an attempt to make democrats look weak
on crime and to burst trump's image
ask the law and order precedent ahead of
the november election
the mayor of chicago says she welcomes a
partnership with federal
agents but she warns against using the
same tactics
as in portland i've been very clear
not happening in chicago we don't need
federal troops
we don't need unnamed secret
federal agents roaming around the
streets of chicago
that's not democracy that we saw
unfolding on the streets
of portland as a result of this federal
action
that's what we call tyranny and
dictatorship
and we are not having it in chicago
residents of chicago say extra police
won't solve the issues facing the city
they say action on gun control would be
more effective
in tackling violent crime and let's head
live now to portland or game where i am
joined by
activist and journalist laura jadeed
laura welcome to the program and uh we
know that you've actually been part of
the protests you've
you've been in them this evening tell us
what you have been witnessing
um well for the last 58 days portland
has been
protesting for black lives matter and
the police brutality in portland and
around the nation
tonight we have been protesting
primarily against the feds after about
11 um
the mayor came out and talked earlier
but recently there was a riot declared
so um if things get loud i do apologize
but it's been a lot of back and forth a
lot of tear gas tonight
the president says for his part that
these federal agents are stepping in in
order to combat rising crime so
what is your response to that
there is no rising crime in portland
oregon there are
protests that have been non-violent
there have been property destruction but
no
no injuries to any human beings by
protesters whatsoever
this is this is not the case trump is
sending these in to quell
civil unrest and to suppress freedom of
speech
the governor uh for her part has said
and i'm quoting here we cannot have
secret police abducting people
um have you witnessed anything like that
um i haven't witnessed it i do know
people who have told me that
they have seen it it's terrifying i mean
the people that have been abducted have
been released within a few hours without
paperwork but
of course there's no guarantee that that
will continue to happen it feels like a
message that they can do whatever they
want to us and there are a lot of people
are very frightened here
talk with us about the resolve among the
protesters especially
you know before the federal agents were
introduced and
after because you know some politicians
they are claiming
that you know the introduction of
federal agents is now just exacerbating
the situation is that something that you
would agree with based upon what you've
been observing on the streets
i would absolutely agree that i would
say that it's galvanized us um
it's become clear that this is an issue
even beyond police brutality which is a
huge issue but
at this point we have to make a stand if
federal agents are coming in
without any kind of identification
kidnapping people off the street
violently suppressing free speech um
using crowd control munitions and in
very responsible and dangerous ways
we have to make a stand against that and
i think all of portland knows that which
is why
we've seen these protests grow from 100
or 202 weeks ago
to thousands today laura
jadid activist and journalist joining us
from the streets of portland oregon
where we have seen protests in recent
days recent weeks
thank you so much for giving us a bit of
perspective there
thank you very much
you